the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
a bunch of X's and a bunch of and a
bunch of wise the wise were univariate
just one real-valued random variable and
the exes were vectors to describe the
bunch of attributes for say each of our
individuals or each of our observations
let's assume now that we're given
essentially only the x's this is
sometime referred to as unsupervised
learning
there's just the X's usually supervision
is done by the by the Y's and so what
you're trying to do is to make sense of
this data you're gonna try to understand
this data represent this data visualize
this data try to understand something
right so if I give you a dimensional
random vectors and you're gonna have n
independent copies of this individual of
this random vector ok so you will see
that I'm gonna have I'm gonna very
quickly run into some limitations about
what I can actually draw on the board
because I'm using boldface here I'm also
gonna use the blackboard boldface so
it's gonna be a bit difficult so let's
tell me if you're actually a little
confused by what is a vector what is the
number and what is a matrix but we'll
get there so I have X in Rd and that's a
random vector and I have X 1 2 X n that
are iid they're independent copies of X
ok so you can think of those as being
the realization of these guys are going
to be a cloud of endpoints in order to
the D and we're gonna think of D as
being fairly large and for this to start
to make sense we're gonna think of D as
being at least 4 ok and meaning that
you're gonna have a hard time
visualizing those things if it was 3 or
2 you would be able to draw this point
and that's pretty much as much sense
you're gonna be making about those guys
just looking at the cloud point all
right so I'm gonna write each of those
X's right so this vector x SD coordinate
and I'm gonna write them as X 1 2 X D
and I'm gonna stack them into matrix
okay so once I have those guys I'm gonna
have a matrix here I'm gonna use the
double bar and it's X 1 transpose X and
transpose so what it means is that the
coordinates of this guy of course are X
1 1 here I have I'm out of size D so I
have X 1 D and here I have x + 1 X and D
and so the I J I throw and J's column is
the matrix X IJ right is the entry X I -
sorry
okay so each so the rows here are the
observations and the columns are the
covariates / attributes okay so this is
an n by d matrix
all right this is really just some
bookkeeping how do we store this data
somehow and the fact that we use a
matrix just like for regression is going
to be convenient because we're getting
able to talk about projections gonna be
able to talk about things like this
all right so everything I'm gonna say
now is about variances or covariances of
those things which means that I need two
moments okay
if the variance does not exist there's
nothing I can say about this problem so
I'm going to assume that the variance
exist and one way to just put it to say
that the two norm of those guys is
finite which is another way to say that
each of them is finite I mean you can
think of it the way you want all right
so now the mean of X right so I have a
random vector so I can talk about the
expectation of X that's a vector that's
in Rd and that's just taking the
expectation entry wise sorry X 1 1 sorry
X 1 ok so I should say it out loud for
this the purpose of this class I will
denote by subscripts the indices that
corresponds to observations and
superscripts the indices that correspond
to coordinates of a variable and that's
I think that's the same convention that
we took for the regression case now of
course you could use whatever you want
if you want to put commas etc it becomes
just a bit more complicated alright then
so now once I have this so this tells me
where my cloud of point is centered
right so if I have a bunch of points ok
so now I have a distribution on Rd so
maybe I should talk about this I'll talk
about this when we talk about the
empirical version but if you think that
you have say a two dimensional Gaussian
random variable then you have a center
in two dimension which is where the
peaks basically and that's what we're
talking about here
but the other thing we want to know is
how much does it spread in every
direction right so in every direction of
the 2-dimensional thing I can try to
understand how much spread I'm getting
and
where you measure this is by using
covariance right so the covariance
matrix Sigma that's a matrix which is d
by D and it records in the JK entry it
records the covariance between the jade
coordinate of X and the Kate coordinate
of X okay so with entries okay so I have
Sigma which is Sigma 1 1 Sigma D D Sigma
1 D Sigma D 1 ok and here I have Sigma
JK and Sigma JK is just the covariance
between X I sorry XJ the Jade coordinate
and the Keith coordinate okay so in
particular it's symmetric because the
covariance between XJ and XK is the same
as the covariance between XK and XJ I
should not put those parentheses here I
do not use them in this okay just the
covariance matrix so that's just
something that records everything and so
what's nice about the covariance matrix
is that if I actually give you X as a
vector
you actually can build a matrix just by
looking at vectors x vectors transpose
rather than actually thinking about
building it coordinate by coordinate so
for example if you're used to using
MATLAB that's the way you want to build
a covariance matrix because MATLAB is
good as at you know manipulating vectors
and matrices rather and just entry it by
entry by entry ok so right so what is
the covariance between XJ and XK now by
definition is the expectation of XJ and
XK minus the expectation of XJ times the
expectation of XK
right that's the definition of the
coherence I hope everybody seen that and
so in particular I can actually see that
this thing can be written as Sigma can
now be written as the expectation of X X
transpose minus the expectation of X
times the expectation of X transpose Y
well let's look at the JK the
coefficient of this guy right so here if
I look at the JK coefficient I see what
well I see that it's the expectation of
X X transpose JK which is equal to the
expectation of X X transpose JK and what
what are the entries of X X transpose
well they're of the form X I XJ times X
K exactly so this is actually equal to
the expectation of XJ times X K and this
is actually not the way I want to write
it that way okay is that clear that when
I have a rank one matrix of this form X
X transpose the entries are of this form
right because if I take for example
think about X Y Z and then I multiply by
X Y Z what I'm getting here is X maybe I
should actually use indices here X 1 X 2
X 3 X 1 X 2 X 3 the entries are X 1 X 1
X 1 X 2 X 1 X 3 X 2 X 1 X 2 X 2 X 2 X 3
X 3 X 1 X 3 X 2 X 3 X 3 okay
so indeed this is exactly of the form if
you look at JK you get exactly XJ times
XK okay
that's the beauty of those matrices so
now once I have this I can do exactly
the same thing except that here if I
take the JK entry I will get exactly the
same thing except that it's not going to
be the expectation of the product but
the product of the expectation right so
I get that the JK entry of a of X Y of X
transpose is just the jth entry of e of
x times the K entry of e of X so if I
put those two together it's actually
telling me that if I look at the JK
entry of Sigma which I called little
Sigma JK
then this is actually equal to what it's
equal to the first term minus the second
term the first term is exponential of is
an expectation of XJ XK minus
expectation of X J expectation of X okay
which oh by the way I forgot to say this
is actually equal to the expectation of
XJ times the expectation of XK because
that's just the definition of the
expectation of random vector so my gen
Mikey are now inside and that's by
definition the covariance between XJ and
XK okay so just if you've seen those
manipulations between vectors hopefully
you're bored out of your mind
and if you have not then that's
something you just need to get
comfortable with right so one thing
that's going to be useful is to know
very quickly what the what's called the
outer product of a vector with itself
which is the vector times the vector
transpose what the entries of this
things are and that's what we've been
using on this on the second set of
boards okay so everybody agrees now that
we've sort of showed that the covariance
matrix can be written in this vector
form so expectation of XX transpose
minus expectation of X expectation of X
transpose
okay just like the covariance can be
written as in two ways right we know
that the covariance can also be written
as the expectation of XJ minus
expectation of XJ times XK minus
expectation of XK right that's the
sometimes this is the original
definition of covariance this is the
second definition of covariance just
like you have the variance which is the
expectation of the square of X minus G
of X or the expectation of X square
minus the expectation of X square it's
the same thing for covariance and you
can actually say this per in terms of
vectors right so this actually implies
that you can also rewrite Sigma as the
expectation of X minus expectation of X
times the same thing transpose right and
the reason is because if you just
distribute those guys this is just the
expectation of well xx transpose minus X
expectation of X transpose minus
expectation of X X transpose and then I
have plus expectation of X expectation
of X transpose now things could go wrong
because the main difference between
matrices / vectors and numbers is that
multiplication does not commute right so
in particular those two things are not
the same thing and so that's the main
difference that we have before but it
actually does not matter for a problem
is because what's happening is that if
when I take the expectation of this guy
then it's actually the same as the
expectation of this guy okay and so just
because the expectation is linear so we
have is that Sigma now becomes equal to
the expectation of XX transpose minus
the expectation of X expectation of X
transpose minus expectation of X
expectation of X transpose and then I
have well really what I have is this guy
and then I have plus expectation of X
expectation of X transpose and now those
three things are actually equal to each
other just because the expectation of X
transpose is the same as the expectation
of X transpose and so what I'm left with
is just the expectation of XX transpose
minus the expectation of X expectation
of X transpose okay so same thing that's
happening when you want to prove that
you can write the covariance either this
way or that way the same thing happens
for matrices for vectors right or
covariance matrix to go together is
there any questions so far
and if you have some please tell me
because I want to I don't know to which
extent you guys are comfortable with
this at all or not okay so let's move on
all right so of course this is what I'm
describing in terms of the distribution
right here I took expectations
covariances are also expectation so
those depend on some distribution of X
right if I wanted to compute that I
would basically need to know what the
distribution of X is now we're doing
statistics so I need to maybe my
question is going to be to say well how
well can I estimate the covariance
matrix itself or some you know
properties of this covariance matrix
based on data
all right so if I want to understand
what my covariance matrix looks like
based on data I'm gonna have to
basically form its empirical
counterparts which I can do by doing the
you know a age-old statistical trick
which is replace your expectation by an
average alright so there's just
everything that's on the board you see
expectation just replace it by an
average okay so now I'm going to be
given X 1 X n so I'm gonna define the
empirical mean okay so really the idea
is take your expectation and replace it
by 1 over n sum right and so the
empirical mean is just 1 over n some of
the exercise I'm guessing everybody
knows how to average vectors it's just
the average of the coordinates so I will
write this as X bar and the empirical
covariance matrix often called sample
covariance matrix
hence the notation s well this is my
covariance matrix right let's just
replace the expectations by averages 1
over n sum from I equal 1 to N of X I X
I transpose - this is a expectation of X
L we'll replace it by the average which
I just called X bar X bar transpose okay
and that's when I want to use the that's
what I want to use the notation the
second definition but I could actually
do exactly the same thing using this
definition here sorry when using this
definition right here so this is
actually 1 over n sum from I equal 1 to
N of X I minus X bar X I minus X bar
transpose and those are actually I mean
in a way it looks like I could define
two different estimators but you can
actually check
I do encourage you to do this if you're
not comfortable making those
manipulations can actually check that
those two things are actually exactly
the same okay
so now I'm gonna want to talk about
matrices okay remember we define this
big matrix X with the double bar and the
question is can i express both X bar and
the sample covariance matrix in terms of
this big matrix X because right now it's
still expressed in terms of the vectors
I'm summing those vectors vectors
transpose the question is can I just do
that in a very compact way you know in a
way that I can actually remove this sum
term all right that's the that's gonna
be the goal I mean that's not a
notational goal that's really something
that we want that's gonna be convenient
for us just like it was convenient to
talk about matrices when we did linear
regression okay
x-bar we just said it's 1 over n sum
from I equal 1 to N of X I right now
remember what does this matrix look like
we said that X bar X is this guy so if I
look at X transpose the rows be the
columns of this guy becomes X 1 my first
observation X 2 my second observation
all the way to X and my last observation
right agreed that's what X transpose is
so if I want to sum those guys I can
multiply by the old ones vector alright
so that's what the definition of the old
ones vector is so it's just a bunch of
ones in our end in this case and so when
I do X transpose 1 what I get is just
the sum from I go 1 to end of the Excise
so if I divide by n I get my average
okay so here I sort of I definitely
removed the some term let's see with the
covariance matrix we can do the same
well that's actually a little more
difficult to see I guess but let's use
this definition for s okay and one thing
that's actually going to be so let's see
for one second what so it's going to be
something that involves X multiplying X
with itself okay and the question is is
it going to be multiplying X with X
transpose or X transpose with X to
answer this question you can go the easy
route which says well my covariance
matrix is of size what what is the size
of s D by D okay X is of size and by D
so if I do x times X transpose I'm gonna
have something which is of size n by n
by dou X transpose X I'm gonna have
something which is d by D that's the
easy route there's basically one of the
two guys you can actually open the box a
little bit and see what's going on in
there if you do X transpose X which we
know gives you an D by D you see that X
is going to have vectors that are of the
form X I and X transpose is going to
have vectors that are of the form X I
transpose right and so this is actually
probably the right way to go so let's
look at what X transpose X is giving us
so I claim that it's actually going to
give us what we want but rather than
actually going there let's - to actually
I mean we could check it entry by entry
but there's actually a nice thing we can
do before we go there let's write X
transpose as the following sum of
variables X 1 and then just a bunch of
zeros everywhere else so it's still d by
n so n minus 1 of the columns are equal
to 0 here then I'm gonna put a 0 and
then put X 2
and then just a bunch of zeros all right
so that's just 0 0 + 0 0 all the way to
xn ok everybody agrees with it see what
I'm doing here
I'm just splitting it into a sum of
matrices that I only have one non-zero
columns but clearly that's true now
let's look at the product of this guy
with itself so let's call this matrices
M 1 M 2 M and so when I do X transpose X
what I do is the sum of the M eyes for
ico 1 to n times the sum of DM I
transpose right now the sum of DM is
transpose is just the sum of the each of
the M is transpose okay so now I just
have this product of two some so I'm
just gonna read X the second one by J so
this is sum for I and equal 1 to J to N
J equal one to n of M I and J transpose
okay and now what we want to notice is
that if I is different from J what's
happening well if I is different from J
let's look at say M 1 times X M 2
transpose
so what is the product between those two
matrices
there's an entry you mean ducks products
again just gonna need one a number right
so I want this is gonna be a matrix it's
a product of two matrices right this is
a matrix times a matrix so this should
be a matrix right of size D by D yeah I
should see a lot of why I can't look
like this right because look at this
right so let's multiply the first let's
look at what's going on in the first
column here I'm multiplying this column
with each of those rows the only nonzero
coefficient is here and it only hits
this column of zeros so every time this
is going to give me 0 0 0 0 and it's
gonna be the same for every single one
of them so this matrix is just full of
zeros right they never hit each other
when I do them out to the matrix matrix
multiplication there's no every nonzero
hits a zero so what it means is and this
of course you can check for every I
different from J so this means that M I
x MJ transpose is actually equal to 0
when I is different from J right
everybody's okay with this so what that
means is that when I do this double sum
really it's a simple sum there's only
just the sum from I equal 1 to n of M I
am i transpose because if this is the
only terms in this double sum that are
not going to be 0 when I eat m1 with m1
itself now let's see what's going on
when I do m1 times M 1 transpose well
now if I do mi times M I transpose now
this guy becomes x1 it's here and so now
I really have X 1 times x1 transpose so
this is really just the sum from I equal
1 to N of X 1 X I X I transpose
okay just because mi mi transposes xixi
transpose there's nothing else there so
that's a good news right this term here
is really just is really just X but X
transpose X divided by n okay I can use
that guy again I guess well no let's
just okay so let me rewrite s alright
that's the definition we have and we
know that this guy already is equal to 1
over N X transpose X X bar X bar
transpose we know that X bar we just
proved that X bar sorry
little X bar was equal to 1 over N X bar
transpose with the times the old ones
vector so I'm just going to do that so
that's just going to be minus I'm gonna
pull my to 1 over ends one from this guy
1 from this guy so I'm gonna get 1 over
N squared and then I'm gonna get X bar
sorry there's no X bar here it's just X
yeah
X transpose all ones times X transpose
all once transpose right and X transpose
all ones transpose right the rule if I
have a times B transpose it's B
transpose times a transpose right
that's just the rule of transposition so
this is one transpose X transpose and so
when I put all these guys together this
is actually equal to 1 over N X
transpose X minus 1 over N squared X
transpose 1 1 transpose X because X
transpose transpose is X ok so now I can
actually have something which is of the
form X transpose X on to the left X
transposed to the right X here I have X
transposed to the left X to the right so
I can factor out whatever is in there so
I can write s as 1 over n sorry X
transpose times 1 over n times the
identity of our D and then I have minus
1 over N 1 1 transpose X ok because if
you I mean you can distribute it back
right so here I'm gonna get what X
transpose identity times X the whole
thing divided by n that's this term and
then the second one is going to be sorry
1 over N squared and then I'm gonna get
1 over N squared times X transpose 1 1
transpose which is this guy times X and
that's the right thing ok so the way
it's written I factored out one of the 1
over N so I'm just gonna do the same
thing at it as it's on as on the slide
so I'm just factoring out this 1 over N
here so it's 1 over N times X transpose
identity of our d divided by n - sorry
divided by one this time minus 1 over N
1 1 transpose times X ok so that's just
what's on the slide
what is the matrix 1 1 transposed look
like it's just all ones right because
the entries are the products of the old
one of the coordinates of the other one
vectors with the coordinates of the
other one vectors so I only get one so
it's a it's a D by D matrix with only
ones so this matrix I can actually write
exactly right H this matrix that I
called H which is what's sandwiched in
between this X transpose in X by
definition I said this is the definition
of H then this thing I can write its
coordinates exactly we know its identity
divided by n minus sorry I don't know
why keep on the PI minus 1 over N 1 1
transpose so it's this matrix with only
ones on the diagonals and zeros
elsewhere - a matrix that only has 1
over N everywhere ok so the whole thing
is 1 minus 1 over N on the diagonals and
then minus 1 over n here ok and now I
claim that this matrix is an orthogonal
projector now I'm writing this but this
completely useless this is just a way
for you to see that it's actually very
convenient now to think about this
problem as being a matrix problem
because things are much nicer when you
think about the actual form of your
matrices right they could tell you here
is the matrix I mean imagine you're
sitting at a midterm and I say here's
the matrix that has 1 minus 1 over N on
the diagonals and minus 1 over N on the
on the off diagonal prove to me that
it's a projector projector matrix you're
gonna have to basically take this guy
times itself is gonna be really
complicated right so we know it's
symmetric that's for sure but the fact
that it has this particular way of
writing it
is gonna make my life super easy to
check this that's the definition of a
projector it has to be symmetric and it
has to square to itself because we just
said in the in the chapter on linear
regression that once you project if you
apply the projection again you're not
moving because you're already there okay
so why is H squared equal to H well
let's just write H square it's the
identity minus 1 over n 1 1 transpose
times the identity minus 1 over N 1 1
transpose right let's just expand this
now this is equal to the identity - well
the identity times 1 1 transpose is just
the identity so it is 1 1 transpose
sorry so 1 over N 1 1 transpose minus 1
over N 1 1 transpose and then there's
gonna be what makes the deal is that
that gets this 1 over N squared this
time and then I get the product of 1
over n trends let's write it completely
I get 1 1 transpose times 1 1 transpose
ok but this thing here what is this and
write this döner product of what the old
ones vector with your ones vector so I'm
just summing n times 1 squared which is
n so this is equal to n so I pull it out
cancel one of the ends and I'm back to
what I had before so I had identity
minus 2 over N 1 1 transpose plus 1 over
N 1 1 transpose which is equal to H
because one of the 1 over n zkn sir ok
so it's a projection matrix it's
projecting onto some linear space right
it's taking a matrix it's the sorry it's
taking a vector it's projecting onto a
certain space of vectors what is this
space all right so how do you so I'm
only asking this question the answer is
question in words right so how would you
describe the vectors onto which this
matrix is projecting well if you want to
answer this question the way you would
tackle it is first by saying okay what
does a vector which is of the form H
times something look like alright what
can I say about this vector that's gonna
be definitely giving me something about
the space on which it projects I need to
know a little more to know that it
projects exactly onto this but one way
we can do this is just see how it acts
on a vector what does it do to a vector
to apply H right so I take V and let's
see what taking V and applying H to it
looks like well is the identity minus
something so he takes V and it removes
something from V what does it remove
well it's 1 over n times V transpose 1
times the old ones vector right agreed I
just wrote V transpose 1 instead of 1 or
instead of well 1 transpose V ok which
are the same thing
what is this thing
but what should I call it in
mathematical notation V bar right I
should call it V bar because this is
exactly the average of the entries of V
green right this is summing the entries
of these and this is dividing by the
number of those V's sorry now V is in R
sorry why do I divide by I'm just okay I
need to check with my dimensions all
right now no it's in our D right so why
do I divide by n so it's not really V
Bar is the sum of the V's divided by
right so it's V Bar
[Music]
oh yeah okay thank you so everywhere I
wrote HD that was actually a channel oh
man I wish I had a computer now all
right so yeah because the the yeah right
so the why it's not what I thought it
was this because I was thinking about
the outer dimension of X really of X
transpose which is really the inner
dimension that mattered to me right so
the thing that I can sandwich between X
transpose and X has to be n by n so this
was actually n by n and so that's
actually and by n everything is n by n
sorry about that so this is and this is
and this is well I didn't really tell
you what all the Oh once vector was but
it's also in our n yeah okay thank you
and and actually I use the fact that
this was of size n here already okay and
so that's indeed V bar so what is this
projection doing to a vector
it's removing its average on each
coordinate right and the effect of this
is that V is a vector what is the
average of HB of HV right so it's zero
it's the average of V which is V Bar
minus the average of something that only
has V bars as entry which is V Bar so
this thing is actually zero so let me
repeat my question
on to what subspace does H project come
to the subspace of vectors that have
mean zero a vector that has been zero is
a vector so if you want to talk more
linear algebra V bar for vector to have
mean zero it means that V is orthogonal
to the span of the all one's vector
that's it it projects onto the space so
in words it projects onto the space of
vectors that have zero mean in linear
algebra it says it projects onto the
hyperplane which is orthogonal to the
old ones vector okay so that's that's
that's all can you guys still see the
screen are you good over there okay
all right so now what it means is that
well I'm doing this word thing right I'm
taking the inner product so s is taking
X and then it's removing its mean of
each of the columns of X right when I
take H times X I'm basically applying
this projection which consists in
removing the mean of all the X's and
then I multiply by H transpose but
what's actually nice is that remember H
is a projector sorry I keep that which
means that when I look at X transpose H
X it's the same as looking at X
transpose H squared X but since H is
equal to H transpose this is actually
the same as looking at X transpose H
transpose HX
which is the same as looking at H X
transpose HX okay
so what is doing its first applying this
projection matrix H which removes the
mean of each of your columns and then
looks at the inner products between
those guys right
it shouldn't we have this guy is just
the covariance between those centroid
things that's all it's doing all right
so those are actually going to be the
key statements so everything we've done
so far is really mainly linear algebra
right I mean looking at expectations and
covariances was just we just use the
fact that the expectation was linear we
didn't do much but now there's a nice
thing that's happening and that's why
we're gonna switch from the language of
linear algebra to more statistical
because what's happening is that if I
look at this so quadratic form right so
I take Sigma so I take a vector U and
I'm gonna look at you so that's saying
Rd and I'm gonna look at you transpose
Sigma you okay what is this doing well
we know that u transpose Sigma u is
equal to what well Sigma is the
expectation of X X transpose minus the
expectation of X expectation of X
transpose right so I just substitute in
there
now you is deterministic so in
particular I can push it inside the
expectation here agree and I can do the
same from the right so here when I push
you transpose here and you here what I'm
left with is the expectation of U
transpose x times X transpose u okay and
now I can do the same thing for this guy
and this tells me that this is the
expectation of U transpose X times the
expectation of X transpose u of course u
transpose X is equal to X transpose u
and u ya so what it means is that this
is actually equal to the expectation of
U transpose x squared minus the
expectation of U transpose X the whole
thing squared but this is something that
should look familiar this is really just
the variance of this particular random
variable which is of the form U
transpose X right u transpose X is a
number it involves a random vector so
it's a random variable and so it has a
variance and this variance is exactly
given by this formula so this is just
the variance of U transpose X so what
we've proved is that if I look at this
guy this is really just the variance of
U transpose X okay
now I can do the same thing for the
sample variance so let's do this and as
you can see spoiler alert this is gonna
be the sample variance okay so remember
s is 1 over n sum of X I X I transpose
minus X bar X bar transpose so what I do
you transpose s you what it gives me is
1 over n sum from I equal 1 to N of you
transpose X I times X I transpose you
alright so those are two numbers that
multiply each other and that happened to
be equal to each other
minus u transpose X bar X bar transpose
u which is also the product of two
numbers that happen to be equal to each
other so I can rewrite this with squares
so we're almost there all I need to know
to check is that this thing is actually
the average of those guys right so you
transpose X bar what is it it's one over
n sum from I 1 to N of u transpose X I
so it's really something that I can
write as u transpose X bar right that's
the average of those random variables of
the form u transpose X I so what it
means is that u transpose su I can write
as 1 over N sum from eiko 1 to n of u
transpose s is re X I squared minus u
transpose X bar squared which is the
empirical variance that we need noted by
small s squared right so that's the
empirical variance of U transpose X 1
all the way to u transpose X n ok and
here same things I use the exactly the
same thing I just use the fact that here
the only thing I use is really the
linearity of this guy of 1 over N sum or
the linearity of expectation that I can
push things in there ok
this one yeah I said its equal to small
s and I want to make a difference
between the bigots that I'm using here
so this is equal to small I'm trying to
make it look like a calligraphic s
squaring okay so this is nice right this
covariance matrix so let's look at
capital Sigma itself right now this
covariance matrix we know that if we
read its entries what we get is the
covariance between the coordinates of
the axis right of the random vector X
and the coordinates well by definition
are attached to a coordinate system so I
only know what the covariance of X
interpret those two things are or the
covariance of those two things are but
what if I want to find coordinates
between linear combination of the X's
sorry if I want to find covariances
between linear combination of those X's
and that's exactly what this allows me
to do it says well if I pre and post x
you this is actually telling me what the
variance of X along Direction U is okay
so there's a lot of information in there
and it's just really exploiting the fact
that there's some linearity going on in
the covariance so wide variance why is
variance interesting for us right why I
started by saying here we're gonna be
interested in having something to do
dimension reduction we have think of
your points as being in dimension larger
than 4 and we're gonna try to reduce the
dimension so let's just think for one
second what do we want about a dimension
reduction process procedure if I have
all my points that live in say three
dimensions and I have one point here in
one point here and one point here and
one point here in one point here and I
decide to project them onto some plane
but I take a plane this just like this
what's gonna happen is that those points
are all gonna project to the same point
all right I'm just gonna not see
anything however if I take a plane which
is like this they're all printed
projecting to some nice line maybe I can
even project them onto a line and they
will still be far apart from each other
so that's what you want you want to be
able to say when I take my points and I
say I project them onto lower dimensions
I do not want them to collapse into one
single points I want them to be spread
as possible in the direction on which I
project and this is what we're gonna try
to do and of course measuring spread
between points can be done in many ways
right I mean you could look at I don't
know the sum of pairwise distances
between those guys you could look at I
know some sort of energy you can look at
many ways to measure spread in a
direction but variance is a good way to
measure spread between points if you
have a lot of variances but the variance
between your points then chances are
they're gonna be spread now this is not
always the case right if I have a
direction in which all my points are
clumped onto one big point and one other
big point is going to choose this
because that's the direction that has a
lot of variance but hopefully the
variance is gonna spread things out
nicely so the idea of of principal
component analysis is going to try to
identify those variances those
directions along which we have a lot of
variance receive reciprocally we're
gonna try to eliminate the directions
along which we do not have a lot of
variance okay and let's see why well if
so here's the first claim if you
transpose su is equal to zero what's
happening well I know that an empirical
variance is equal to zero what does it
mean for an empirical variance to be
equal to zero so I give you a bunch of
points right so those points are those
points you transpose x1 you turn those
are a bunch of numbers what does it mean
to have the empirical variance of those
points being equal to 0 they're all the
same so what it means is that when I
have my points right so can you find the
direction for those points in which they
project to all the same point no right
there is no such thing for this to
happen you have to have your points
which are perfectly aligned and then
when you're going to project onto the
orthogonal
of this guy they're gonna all project to
the same point here which means that the
empirical variance is going to be zero
now this is an extreme case this will
never happen in practice because if that
happens well I mean you can basically
figure that out very quickly so in the
same way it's very unlikely that you're
gonna have you transpose Sigma u which
is equal to zero which means that
essentially all your points are
emotionally or let's say all of them are
orthogonal to you right it's exactly the
same thing just says that in the
population case there's no probability
that your points deviate from this guy
here this happens with no probability
okay and that's just because if you look
at the variance of this guy it's going
to be zero and then that means that
there's no deviation by the way I'm
using the name projection when I talk
about you transpose X right so let's
just be clear about this if you so let's
say I have a bunch of points and U is a
vector in this direction and let's say
that U has so this is zero this is U and
let's say that you as norm one okay when
I look what is the coordinate of the
projection so what is the length of this
guy here that's called this guy x1 what
is the length of this guy in terms of
inner products this is exactly u
transpose x1 this length here if this is
X - this is exactly U transpose X - okay
so those u transpose X measure exactly
the distance to the origin of those of
those having the it's really think of it
as being just an x-axis thing you just
have a bunch of points you have an
origin and it's really just telling you
what the coordinate on this axis is
gonna be right so in particular if the
empirical variance is 0 it means that
all these points project to the same
which means that they have to be
orthogonal to this guy and you can think
of this being also maybe an entire plane
that's orthogonal to this line okay so
that's why I talk about projection
because the inner products U transpose X
is really measuring the coordinate of X
when u becomes the y axis the x axis
now if u has does not have norm one then
you just have a change of scale here you
just have a change of unit right so this
is really u times x1 the coordinate
should really be divided by the norm of
U okay so now just in the same way so
we're never gonna have exactly zero but
if we're good in the other end if u
transpose su is large what does it mean
it means that when I look at my points
as projected onto the axis generated by
u they're gonna have a lot of variance
they're gonna be far away from each
other in average right
that's what large variance means or at
least large empirical variance means and
same thing for you so what we're gonna
try to find is au that maximizes this if
I can find out u that maximizes this so
I can look in every direction and
suddenly find a direction in which the
spread is massive then that's a point on
which I'm basically the less likely to
have my points project them to each
other and collide right at least I know
they're gonna project at least onto two
points so that's basic so the idea now
is to say okay let's try to maximize
this this spread right so we're gonna
try to find the maximum overall use of U
transpose su and that's gonna be the
direction that maximizes the empirical
variance now of course if I write it
like that for all use in our D what is
the value of this maximum
it's infinity right because I can always
multiply you by 10 and this entire thing
is going to be multiplied by 100 so I'm
just gonna take you as large as I want
and this thing is gonna be as large as I
want and so I need to constrain you and
as I said I need to have you of size
want to talk about coordinates in the
system generated by you like this so I'm
just going to constrain you to have norm
you clean normal to one okay
so that's gonna be my goal trying to
find the largest possible u transpose su
R in other words empirical variance of
the points projected on to the direction
you when you is of norm one which
justifies to use the word direction and
because there's no magnitude to this you
okay so how am I going to do this right
that could just like fold and say let's
just optimize this thing right let's
just take this problem it says maximize
a function onto some constraints
immediately the constraint is sort of
nasty I'm on like a sphere and I'm
trying to move points on the sphere and
I'm maximizing this thing which actually
happens to be convex and we know we know
how to minimize convex functions but
maximize them is a different question
and so this problem is might be super
hard so I can just like say okay here's
what I want to do and let me give that
to an optimizer and just hope that the
optimizer can solve this problem for me
that's one thing we can do now as you
can imagine PCA so well spread right
principal component analysis is
something that people do constantly and
so that means that we know how to do
this fast
so that's one thing the other thing that
you should probably question about why
if this thing is actually difficult why
in the world would you even choose the
variance as a measure of spread is
there's so many measures of spread right
the variance is one measure of spread
it's not guaranteed that everything is
going to project nicely far apart from
each other so you know we could choose
the variance but you could choose
something else if the variance does not
help why choose it turns out the
variance helps so this is indeed a non
convex problem I'm maximizing so it's
actually the same I can make this count
this
this constraint convex because I'm
maximizing your convex function so it's
clear that the maximum is gonna be
attained at the boundary so I can
actually just fill this ball into some
convex ball however I'm still maximizing
so this is a non convex problem and this
turns out to be the fanciest non convex
problem we know how to solve and the
reason why we know how to solve it is
not because of optimization or using
gradient type things or anything of the
algorithms that I mentioned during
linear during the maximum likelihood is
because of linear algebra then your
algebra guarantees that we know how to
solve this and to understand this we
need to go a little deeper in linear
algebra and we need to understand the
concept of diagonalization of a matrix
so who has ever seen the concept of an
eigenvalue and that's beautiful and if
you're not raising your hand you're just
playing candy crush right alright so
okay so this is great everybody's seen
it for my live audience of millions
maybe you have not so well so go through
it alright so what one of the basic fact
and I remember when I learned this in in
in I mean when I was an undergrad I
learned about the spectral decomposition
and this diagonalization of matrices and
from it was just a structural property
of matrices but it turns out that it's
extremely useful it's useful for
algorithmic purposes and so what this
theorem tells you is that if you take a
symmetric matrix with well with real
entries but that's really does not
matter so much and here I'm gonna
actually so I take a symmetric matrix
and actually s and Sigma are 2 such
symmetric matrices right then there
exist P and D which are both so let's
say a D by D which are bullet of I D
such that P is orthogonal that means
that P transpose P is equal to P P
transpose is equal to the identity and D
is diagonal and Sigma let's say is equal
to P D P transpose okay so it's the
diagonalization because it's finding a
nice transformation P has some nice
properties it's really just a change of
coordinates in which your matrix is
diagonal alright and the way you want to
see this and I think sort of it sort of
helps to think about this problem as
being Sigma being a covariance matrix
what is the covariance matrix tali-rite
think of a multivariate Gaussian can
everybody visualize the two dimensional
Gaussian density
alright so it's gonna be some sort of
bell-shaped curve but it's good it might
be more elongated in one direction than
another and then I'm gonna chop it like
that
alright so I'm gonna chop it off and and
I'm gonna look at you know how it bleeds
alright so I'm just gonna look at where
the blot is and what's gonna look that
it's gonna look like some sort of some
sort of episode right and high dimension
is just gonna be you know an olive and
then it's just gonna be bigger okay chop
it off a little lower and I get
something a little bigger like this and
so it turns out that Sigma is capturing
exactly this right the matrix Sigma so
the the center of your covariance matrix
of your Gaussian is going to be this
thing and Sigma is going to tell you
which direction that's elongated alright
and so in particular if you look if you
know an ellipse you know there's
something called principal axis right so
you can actually define something that
looks like this which is this axis the
one along which is the most elongated
then the axis along which it's which is
orthogonal to it along which it's
slightly less elongated and you go again
and again along the orthogonal ones it
turns out that those things here is the
new coordinate system in which this
transformation p and p transpose is
putting you into
dee has entries on the diagonal which
are exactly this length and this length
all right so that's just what it's doing
it's just telling you well if you think
of having this like Gaussian or dislike
high dimensional ellipsoid it's
elongated along certain directions and
these directions are actually maybe not
well aligned with your original
coordinate system which might just be
the usual one right nor thousand
east-west maybe I need to turn it and
that's exactly what this orthogonal
transformation is doing for you all
right so you know what this is actually
telling you even more it's telling you
that any matrix that's symmetric you can
actually turn it somewhere now start to
dilate things in the directions that you
have and then turn it back to what you
originally had and that's actually
exactly the effect of applying a
symmetric matrix to a vector right there
and it's sort of pretty impressive it
says if I take Sigma times V but for any
Sigma that's of this form what I'm doing
is that symmetric what I'm really doing
to V is I'm changing its coordinate
system so I'm rotating it then I'm
changing I'm multiplying its coordinates
and then I'm rotating it back that's all
it's doing and that's what all symmetric
matrices do which means that this is
doing a lot all right so ok so what do I
know so I'm not going to prove that this
is the so-called spectral theorem and
the diagonal entries of D is of the form
lambda 1 lambda 2 lambda D 0 0 and the
lambda J's are called eigen values of D
now in general those numbers can be
positive negative or equal to 0
but here I know that Sigma and s are
while they're symmetric for sure but
they are positive semi-definite
what does it mean it means that when I
take you transpose Sigma you for example
this number is always non-negative why
is this true what is this number
it is the variance of and actually I
don't even need to finish this sentence
as soon as I say that this is a variance
but it has to be non-negative we know
that the variance is not negative and so
that's also a nice way you can use stats
is just to say well okay this thing is
positive semi-definite because it's a
covariance matrix so I know it's a it's
a it's a variance okay so I get this now
if I had some negative numbers so the
effect of that is that when I draw this
picture those axes are always positive
which is kind of a weird thing to say
but what it means is that when I take a
vector V I rotate it and then I stretch
it in the directions of the coordinate I
cannot flip it I can only stretch or
shrink but it cannot flip its sign all
right but in general for any symmetric
matrices I could do this but when it's
positive symmetric definite actually
what turns out is that all the lambda
J's are non-negative I cannot flip it
okay so all the eigenvalues are
non-negative
that's the property of positive
semi-definite so when it's symmetric you
have the eigenvalues they can be any
number and when it's positive
semi-definite in particularly that's the
case of the covariance matrix and the
empirical covariance matrix right
because the empirical covariance matrix
is an empirical variance which itself is
non-negative and so I get that the eigen
values are non-negative
all right so
principal component analysis is saying
okay I want to find the direction V U
that maximizes u transpose su alright
I've just introduced in one slide
something about eigenvalues so hopefully
they should help all right so what is it
that I'm gonna be getting well let's
just see what happens
oh I forgot to mention and I will use
this so the lambda G's are called eigen
vectors and then the matrix P as columns
V 1 to V D okay the fact that it's
orthogonal that P transpose P is equal
to the identity means that those guys
satisfy that di transpose V J is equal
to 0 if I is different from J and VI
transpose V I is actually equal to 1
right because the entries of PP
transpose are exactly going to be of the
form VI transpose VJ okay so those V's
are called eigenvectors and v1 is
attached to lambda 1 and V 2 is attached
to lambda 2 okay so let's see what's
happening with those things what happens
if I take Sigma so if you know
eigenvalues you know exactly what's
gonna happen if I look at say Sigma
times V 1 well what is Sigma we know
that Sigma is P D P transpose V 1 what
is P transpose times V 1 well P
transpose as rows V 1 transpose V 2
transpose all the way to V G transpose
so when I multiply this by V 1 what I'm
left with is the first coordinate is
going to be equal to 1
and second coordinate is going to be
equal to zero right because there are
Seconal to each other
zero all the way to the end so that's
when I do PD transpose V one now I
multiply by D well I'm just multiplying
this by this guy by lambda one this guy
by lambda two and this guy by lambda T
so this is really just lambda one and
now I need to post multiply by P so what
is P times this guy well P is V one all
the way to VD and now I multiply by a
vector that only has zeros except lambda
one on the first guy so this is just
lambda 1 times V 1 so what we've proved
it that Sigma times V 1 is lambda 1 V 1
and that's probably the notion of eigen
value you're most comfortable with right
so just when I multiply by V 1 I get V 1
back multiplied by something which is
the eigen value so in particular if I
look at V 1 transpose Sigma V 1 what do
I get
well I get lambda 1 V 1 V 1 transpose of
V 1 transpose V 1 which is 1 right so
this is actually lambda 1 V 1 transpose
V 1 which is lambda 1 ok and if I do the
same with V 2 clearly I'm gonna get V 2
transpose Sigma V 2 is equal to lambda 2
so for each of the V J's I know that if
I look at the variance along the V J
it's actually exactly given by those
eigen values all right which proves this
because the variance sorry the variance
along the eigenvectors is actually equal
to the eigenvalues so since they're
variances they have to be non-negative
so now I'm looking for the one for the
one direction that has the most variance
right but that's not only among the
eigenvectors
that's also among the other directions
that are in between the eigenvectors if
I were to look only at the eigenvectors
it would just tell me well just pick the
eigenvector VJ that's associated to the
largest of the lambda J's well it turns
out that that's also true for any vector
that the maximum direction is actually
one direction which is among the
eigenvectors and among the eigenvectors
we know that the one that's the largest
that carries the largest variance is the
one that's associated to the largest
eigenvalue all right and so this is what
PCA is gonna try to do for me so in
practice that's what I mentioned already
right we're trying to project a point
cloud onto a low dimensional space
d-prime by keeping as much information
as possible and buy as much information
I mean we do not want points to collide
and so what PCA is gonna do is just
gonna try to project onto directions so
there's gonna be a u and then there's
gonna be something orthogonal to you and
then a third one etc so that once we
project on those we're keeping as much
of the covariance as possible okay and
in particular those directions that
we're gonna pick are actually a subsets
of the V J's that are associated to the
largest eigen values so I'm gonna stop
here for today we'll finish this on on
Tuesday but basically the idea is that
it's just the following you're just
going to well let me just keep one more
yeah this is the idea you're first gonna
pick the eigenvector associated to the
largest eigenvalue then you're going to
pick the larger the direction that's
orthogonal to the leading and get the
vector that you've picked and that's
carrying the most variance and that's
actually the second largest the
eigenvector associate to the second
largest eigenvalue
and you're gonna go all the way to the
number of them that you actually want to
pick which is in this case D okay and
wherever you choose to chop this process
not going all the way to D is going to
actually give you a lower dimensional
representation in the coordinate system
that's given by v1 v2 v3 etc okay so
we'll see that in more details on
Tuesday but I don't want to get into it
now we don't have enough time are there
any questions